[Música]
hace 3.500 años en Egipto Un noble
faraón fue víctima de un ataque violento
pero el ataque no fue físico este faraón
había muerto hacía 20 años el ataque fue
histórico un acto de damnasio memoria y
la condenación de la memoria alguien
destruyó sus estatuas e intentó borrar
de la historia con un cincel su nombre e
Imagen Quién era este faraón y que había
detrás del ataque
Esta es la clave El faraón era mujer en
el curso normal de las cosas nunca
debería haber sido faraón Aunque era
legal y las mujeres podían ser Monarcas
esto perturbaba algunas creencias
egipcias primero El faraón era conocido
como la Encarnación viviente del dios
masculino horus segundo perturbar la
tradición patriarcal era un serio
desafío al Matt palabra para verdad que
expresaba creencia en el orden y la
justicia vitales para los egipcios hat
quizá trató de adaptarse a esta creencia
mediante la relación entre orden y
patriarcado a través de sus títulos tomó
el nombre matcare y a veces se refería a
sí misma como
terminación de palabra masculina pero al
parecer estos esfuerzos no convencieron
a todos y quizás alguien borró la imagen
de hatsud para que el mundo olvidara la
perturbación al mar y el Egipto
recuperara el equilibrio
además no era la heredera legítima al
Trono sino una especie de regente de
comonarca interina la realeza egipcia
tradicionalmente pasaba de padres a
hijos pasó de tutmosis primero a su hijo
tutmosis segundo el marido de hatsup
debería haber pasado de tutmosis segundo
directamente a su hijo tutmosis tercero
pero tutmosis tercero era un niño
pequeño cuando murió su padre
la primera esposa y viuda del faraón se
autoproclamó regente de su hijastro pero
y no gobernando junto a él como faraón
de pleno derecho quizás tutmosis tercero
se haya enojado por esto y haya borrado
las imágenes también es posible que
alguien quisiera deshonrar a hatchepsut
por mala faraona pero la evidencia
sugiere que era bastante buena fue
competente al cumplir los roles
administrativos tradicionales fue una
gran constructora su templo funerario
yeser yesero fue un fenómeno
arquitectónico para la época Y todavía
es admirado hoy mejoró la economía de
Egipto y dirigió una misión comercial
muy exitosa a la lejana tierra de punto
tenía fuertes conexiones religiosas
incluso afirmaba ser hija del Dios Amón
y Tuvo una exitosa carrera militar con
una campaña novia y sostuvo que luchó
junto a sus soldados en batalla por
supuesto tenemos que tener cuidado al
evaluar el éxito de la carrera de
hatchepsut ya que la mayoría de la
evidencia fue escrita la propia
hatchepsud cuenta su propia historia en
imágenes y por escrito en los muros de
su templo funerario y en la capilla roja
que construyó para Amón entonces quién
cometió los crímenes contra la memoria
de hatchepsut El sospechoso más popular
es su hijastro sobrino y cogobernante
tutmosis tercero lo hizo por enojo Dado
que ella le robó el trono es poco
probable ya que el daño no se hizo hasta
20 años después de la muerte de
mucho tiempo para quedarse enojado y
luego actuar por rabia
quizás tutmosis tercero quiso hacer que
su propio reinado pareciera más fuerte
pero es más probable que él u otra
persona borrase las imágenes para que la
gente olvidara que una mujer alguna vez
ocupó el trono egipcio esta anomalía de
género simplemente era una amenaza muy
grande al Matt y debía ser borrada de la
historia felizmente los antiguos
sensores no eran tan minuciosos se
conservan bastantes pruebas que nos
permiten reconstruir lo que pasó Así que
ahora puede contarse la historia de esta
mujer poderosa y única
siga a la antigua médica egipcia PC
mientras cuida y trata a sus pacientes y
descubra Cómo eran la medicina y la
sanación en esta civilización temprana
con este video